- I'm not just talking
about the left and liberals.
Let's not forget,
let's not have a short memory.
You know, when
this pandemic hit,
you actually tried to make me
work out things with Sam Harris.
I mean, we had conservatives,
people that were
more in the middle,
that were saying
"No, lockdowns now.
At least for now, at least
for a couple of weeks."
And I was always like,
"Hell no, hell no.
I know what this is,
it's paralyzing fear.
You're showing us..."
Uniquely, even the death count.
I mean, how bizarre for a
news organization to say,
"Stay at home,"
and then every
time somebody dies,
just add a number on the screen.
I mean, that's literally a
game of psychological fear,
right?
And I knew what was
coming around the corner.
And it shocked me how much
people, left and right,
were willing to give
up their freedom
because they had a little
bit of fear, right?
It shocked me.
I wasn't one of them.
And I know that lot of
people have come around,
on the conservative side,
and said, "No more."
But, how do we get
people to understand
that we can't get to the point
where you say, "No more."
It has to be "Never,"
right in the beginning,
when you're feeling fearful.
You can't say, "Well, I
was okay with the lockdowns
for two weeks.
But, you know what? One year's
a little too long for me."
Right? You've already lost the-
(intriguing music)
- All right.
We are on location,
on the set of Candice.
And I'm with Candace Owens,
on your set, lady.
Not too shabby!
- I've come a long way.
- You have come a long way.
- You've being one of my
first interviews on your set,
so there we go.
- That's right.
Everyone knows the
story between us
and knows our history.
But, real quick,
to recap in one minute,
when I brought you onto
my show originally,
we were doing YouTube Week.
We were just trying to
find like anyone on YouTube
doing anything interesting.
We found this girl,
Red Pill Black.
I did not know your name
until we sat down
in those chairs,
a minute before we started.
And now,
you've basically like
lit the world on fire.
- Yeah, yeah.
It's crazy to
think back at like,
so much I didn't even know then.
Like, I, obviously,
was not looking to
get into politics.
And if I look back
on that interview,
I feel so young, you know?
Like so,
not really knowing what
I was stumbling upon,
but knowing I kinda
had this feeling
that something was really wrong
and I had been lied to.
And wow,
what a whirlwind it's been
over the last four years.
- So, out of all the people
that I've interviewed,
and we've talked about
this many times privately.
But, out of all the
people that I interviewed,
we finished that
first interview,
I turned to David,
I was like, "That girl is
going to be a superstar."
It was just so obvious.
But, did you have
this plan at all?
Like, I know you
were kinda curious,
and you were figuring it out,
and there were one or two things
that I asked you about politics
that you were kinda
like, "I don't know yet.
I don't want to
comment on that yet."
Which I thought was pretty
impressive, actually.
But, you have just
like marched forward.
The machine has
tried to destroy you
how many times now?
- Yeah. (laughs)
- You keep a running count?
- Definitely have lost count.
And you know, I think, again,
kind of hinting at the naivety
of that first interview,
which is really
beautiful to watch,
is that I just never
could have imagined
that people would
try to destroy me.
I never would have
imagined, even,
that I wasn't allowed to not
have an opinion on some things,
that I wasn't allowed
to grow as a person
and say, "I'm still learning."
Because I was still learning.
I had ideas and
feelings about things,
but I didn't really have
the facts on my side.
And I had no idea that
when you're in politics,
they're just looking
to expose you.
And "She's a fake,
she's a fraud.
Oh, look, she doesn't
know this, she's stupid."
So, I had to grow up
pretty quick, you know?
And really kind of sharpen
my figurative sword,
and really get ready,
and do a lot of studying.
But, yeah,
I could have never imagined.
I had no plan. I was just
saying what I thought to be real
and what I thought to be true.
- Yeah. And I know that
you're not just saying it
because every time
I've been with you,
when we've done road gigs
together, or whatever,
you've got ten books with you.
We had dinner at your
house last night,
you're working on farming now.
Like, you're always just
trying to learn more and more.
And I will be welcomed at
your off-location site, right?
When the grid goes down
and everything else happens.
- Yeah,
when the grid goes down, yeah.
I, actually,
as you just hinted on,
I'm kinda going
through this thing now
where I realize that
we are all dependents,
and we are all on welfare,
if we don't know how to grow
food and support ourselves.
And I think that
that really speaks
to the drama of
this administration,
of realizing that...
I know a lot of Americans
empathize with the idea
that we feel like we're
losing our country,
and that we really have
communists in the White House.
And you know,
we are watching all of
Americans be depressed.
And, in that vein,
I said to myself,
"If this really
does hit," right?
"If we are suddenly living
in a communist country
in three years, four years,
or however you wanna call it,
can I fend for myself?"
- Two months, I think.
- Yeah, two months, right.
"Can I fend for myself?
Can I grow my own food?
What do I know about
living off of the land?"
So, that is something,
yeah, that I'm just
now learning now.
And what better place to do
it than in Tennessee, right?
I mean, everybody's
farming, hunting.
So, yeah,
that's kind of another thing
that I'm exploring now.
- Can you believe that
you live in Tennessee?
I mean, I said to
you guys last night,
like you so were obviously
in the right place.
So happy,
and the house is great,
and little George is great.
Like, you've just embraced it.
But, do you kind of sit back
and go, "Wow, I ended
up in Tennessee.
Five years ago,
little YouTuber from Philly,
and here I am now."
And on your own set,
with your own crew,
and the whole thing.
- Married to an
Englishman in Tennessee.
If you had said to me that
first day that we sat down,
like, "Here's
what's gonna happen.
You're gonna end up living
in Nashville, Tennessee,
and you're gonna be
married to an Englishman
that you will have
gotten engaged to
after two weeks of
knowing each other."
I would have thought
you were nuts.
And my life has
been pretty nuts,
and pretty unpredictable.
Tennessee, in my heart,
I think I maybe thought
I would end up in Texas.
I love Texas,
I love the Texans.
And, obviously,
opportunity came
knocking in Tennessee.
And now that I'm here,
I could never imagine
living anywhere else.
Like, this is fully where
we wanna raise our family.
We think it is the
greatest state.
We love the people.
There really is something
about the Tennesseans.
- Yeah.
Do you think America is just,
this is how it's gonna be,
you're just gonna
have to move to places
that are more in line
with your values?
Or, is there a point
of someone staying
in say, California, or New York,
and fighting?
Do you think that that point,
have we crossed that already?
- I do not think
that there will ever be a
clean election in California.
I think that Gavin Newsom
has made sure that
that can't happen.
To say,
"mail-in ballots
into perpetuity"?
Forget it, no.
New York City,
I don't have much
hope for either.
I can't imagine...
I mean, when I go
to New York City,
it's like already stepping
into a communist country,
where the people are okay
with their oppressions.
I mean, the idea of
having to show papers
every time you walk
into a restaurant,
or have a transaction,
that's actually not America.
So, I would almost say
that that's not a
future prediction,
that's a present one,
like in New York and California.
And I should say
more Los Angeles,
I shouldn't say the whole
state of California.
But, those are not
American cities.
- What has that told you about,
or what have you learned
about just humans?
The way a certain set of
people just want more.
That's what I feel
like in Los Angeles,
when I walk around.
I'm like, "Man,
you guys like this
and you're begging
for more control."
That's been a very weird
thing to kinda realize.
- Yeah.
What it says to me
is that fear is one
hell of a currency.
And I have been hitting
on this on my own show,
of making people
aware of the fact
that the second
somebody can identify
what it is that you
are fearful over,
they can exert control over you.
And I don't think that we have
ever seen that displayed more
than in the COVID-19
circumstances.
And I'm not just talking
about the left and liberals.
Let's not forget,
let's not have a short memory.
You know, when
this pandemic hit,
you actually tried to make me
work out things with Sam Harris.
I mean, we had conservatives,
people that were
more in the middle,
that were saying
"No, lockdowns now.
At least for now, at least
for a couple of weeks."
And I was always like,
"Hell no, hell no.
I know what this is,
it's paralyzing fear.
You're showing us..."
Uniquely, even the death count.
I mean, how bizarre
for a news organization
to say, "Stay at home."
And then, every
time somebody dies,
just add a number on the screen.
I mean,
that's literally a game
of psychological fear,
right?
And I knew what was
coming around the corner.
And it shocked me how much
people, left and right,
were willing to give
up their freedom
because they had a little
bit of fear, right?
It shocked me.
I wasn't one of them.
And I know that lot of
people have come around,
on the conservative side,
and said "No more."
But, how do we get
people to understand
that we can't get to the
point where you say "No more."
It has to be, "Never,"
right in the beginning,
when you're feeling fearful.
You can't say, "Well, I
was okay with the lockdowns
for two weeks.
But, you know what?
One year is a little
too long for me." Right?
You've already lost the game.
- Right, as we're about to roll
into year three, basically.
- Right.
It was never okay.
- Yeah.
- And I think that,
because I'm a bit
more of a gut player,
and because I
truly do understand
how sinister governments can be,
it's been the story of
human history since forever,
I'm never willing to give
up a little bit of freedom
for a little bit of safety.
- It's so funny to me
because since I
know you privately,
and as a friend,
I know that the stuff that
you talk about publicly,
even when I'm like, "Ah,
Candace went a little
overboard on that one."
I'm like,
"I know that is you.
That really is you."
And we told this story once,
but the day that
lockdown started,
you were on my show in LA.
We didn't know, at the
time we were taping,
that lockdowns were
about to happen.
- Right.
- You were, literally,
coughing up blood.
You were coughing up blood.
Your friend, or your
assistant at the time,
was there also.
She was sick.
David's looking at me like,
"We're gonna be trapped
in the house for months
with Candace.
You could die here.
Like, it's all over."
But, you were just like, "No,
I don't have COVID, I'm fine.
It has something to do with
the pillows at the hotel.
And everyone's insane,
and I'm gonna get the
hell out of here."
- Yeah.
That was so funny,
actually, in retrospect.
Like, the worst timing
of me having an allergic
reaction to feathered pillows.
And like your husband
was not buying it.
He's like, "No, no, no,
she's dying of COVID."
Like, Googling to see
what was happening.
But, yeah.
And that was actually
the last event I did
before they sort of
locked down everything,
and all my events
necessarily got canceled.
But, not because of me,
I mean, I attended everything.
I was pregnant during COVID,
I traveled the country,
I traveled the world.
I went to Croatia,
I went to England.
I just did not have this fear.
I can't explain it.
It was too convenient.
And it also, obviously,
didn't help their case
that they had predicted
the coronavirus pandemic
at The World Economic
Forum, a year prior.
I think what we're
dealing with right now
is a very sinister,
evil, globalist agenda.
And that is not a conspiracy,
I think that is a fact.
And they want to exert control
over every single
element of our lives.
And, unfortunately,
you have people that are
pliable to that control
because they're fearful.
And also, people
that are just lazy.
So, one element
is that people are
happy to be controlled
because they're fearful.
The other element is
because control is easy.
If you don't have to
think for yourself,
and somebody just
plugs you into a system
and says, "Do this."
I mean,
freedom is hard.
Freedom is hard work.
Personal responsibility is hard.
Growing your own vegetables.
Hey, that's pretty hard.
Right? It's kinda easy to
just go to the grocery store
and have it being prepared.
- Yeah.
- People don't like to do
things that are difficult,
they want things to be
handed easily for them.
And that's why we
have, you know,
the extraordinary welfare
system that we have.
- Why are you not afraid?
I know you're not.
But, everyone is basically
afraid, seemingly.
But, I dunno,
is it your wiring?
Is it something you
learned very early on?
Like, why do you always...
You see the thing
in the distance
and you just go right to it.
For as many times as Twitter
tried to take you out,
or New York Times,
or whoever it is,
you just keep going,
and going, and going.
- Yeah.
I get that question
all the time.
And the truth is that I'm my
Granddaddy's Granddaughter.
I mean, he just was a tough guy.
He just passed in September.
I've just dedicated
my book to him,
my first book to him.
And, you know,
I have just always
looked at my life
in comparison to his.
And it's the reason why,
when people talk about
their oppression,
I think of a man who grew
up in segregated South,
who never, ever, ever spoke
about being oppressed,
never spoke about why
people were racist,
never spoke about how the
white man was after him.
He just got up every
day and he worked.
And he did that from the
time he was five-years-old
on a sharecropping farm.
I find this generation
of individuals
to be a little bit pathetic.
I think we're a little bit
pathetic. I think, you know,
the Greatest Generation
that ever lived,
yielded the most pathetic
generation that's ever lived,
which is walking among us today.
We just can't do
anything for ourselves.
And I don't wanna be that.
And the other thing is
I'm just wired this way.
I was like this since
I was a little girl.
My parents always
tell stories about me.
Like, I was just one of
those precocious kids
that just never allowed an adult
to tell me what to
do without reason.
I never responded to
arbitrary authority.
I was one of those kids that,
if your parents were like,
"Well, clean your bed
or Santa's not gonna come."
I would say like, "You
tell him not to come."
Right?
(David laughing)
And so, they were
always laughing,
and having to close a
door to reprimand me
because I was kind of
like this little adult.
And I think my
character is really just
that I respect authority,
but the authority
can't be arbitrary.
It needs to make sense.
And if it doesn't make sense,
and you're okay with it,
then that sets up the
grounds for slavery.
And I'm not a slave.
- You are not a slave,
that is for sure.
But, will you be a politician?
- Will I be a politician? I
get this question all the time.
And I used to say "No,"
and now I say,
"Never say never."
I've had those conversations
with my husband before
about what it would
actually mean.
And I definitely would
never be in Congress,
I can tell you, absolutely not.
I've done two of those hearings.
I would rather, honestly,
pull out all of my fingernails.
- That was one of
your best moments.
The one with you and Ted
Lieu was really incredible.
And then, remember,
we had that event.
I forget, I don't even remember
where we were that night.
But, you left that event,
you destroyed everyone there,
and then you just go
on with your life.
- "Bye," yeah.
I mean,
these people are
just are real losers,
heading up all these hearings.
But-
- But, are you nervous
in any of those things?
Like, I do this
for a living too,
and I don't really get nervous,
but I haven't sat
in front of Congress
and just destroyed them.
- Let me tell you something,
Congress works for you,
not the other way around.
I actually think
that the way that that whole
little auditorium is set up
is wrong.
Why are they above me?
I should be-
- Literally, they're...
- Yeah, they're
literally above you.
And I believe that we should
literally be above them.
I don't even like
the way it's set up.
And this is the idea.
We've gotten this idea
that they're above us,
they're not.
They literally work for us.
And the majority of them,
on the Democrat side,
are a bunch of scumbags.
And they're working to
destroy this country.
They've sold us out.
A lot of them have
been in DC forever,
and are just corrupt and trying
to fill their own pockets.
So, I had no fear.
I was angry at
the obvious set up
and the attempt to play me.
And I was happy
that I was able to expose
them for what they were.
But, I don't have fear of people
that are essentially
my employees.
- Do you have anyone that
you've been trying to talk to,
to get into a debate with,
that has refused?
There's gotta be some.
But, you've done
a couple of these.
Like, with Russell Brand,
who you had major
differences with,
and a couple other people.
I find it very hard
to get these people
to talk at this point
because we are racist,
homophobic, bigots.
(both laughing)
Is there anyone
that's on your list
that you feel like if you
could just get them to break,
maybe it would do
something really big?
- Not any more
because obviously there's just
been this long frustration
with realizing that they
love to talk about you
to garner clicks.
But, when you say,
"Hey, show up.
If you're about it, show up."
They always say, "No." I
mean, I think even last week,
we invited Ana Kasparian.
I think she's dedicated
hours, and hours,
hours of coverage of me.
And I have dedicated
literally zero seconds
of coverage to her.
And I said, "Okay, let's
have her on the show
and have a civil conversation."
And she declined.
So,
Russell Brand is an
amazing human being.
He really is.
And he's saying stuff,
the reason why he was
willing to host me
and has been willing
to host others
is because he genuinely
believed what he was saying.
Right?
If you genuinely believe
what you are saying,
even if it's wrong,
but you believe it to be true,
I can deal with that.
Right?
And we can talk, and we
can have a conversation,
because we both
wanna become better,
and we both wanna
discover the truth.
If you know what you
are saying is a lie,
and you tell that lie day in
and day out, you have to hide,
right?
Because you can't face yourself
and you can't face the truth.
So, I always think that
that kind of marks the
difference in the personalities
that we see on the left.
And there's not too many of them
that are willing to sit down
with people on the right.
- Has some of that
sort of translated
to how you do your show?
Because you're doing something,
that I'm trying to do as well,
which is not make people crazy.
I'm really not.
I'm actually trying
to do the reverse.
I want people, if they watch,
by the end, to be like, "Ah,
I laughed a couple of times.
Oh, I thought about this."
But, I'm not like, insane.
And almost everyone now
that's in our space
is almost designed to
make everybody crazy.
- It's actually
funny you say that
because I would say
about five episodes ago,
maybe a few more, I kinda
sit down with the team
and I said, "Let's make
the show more positive."
Right?
Because the feeling
that I was getting
of even reporting on
some of this stuff
was it was just
getting so depressing
and so overwhelming.
And I was like,
"There's a way to still
tell people what's going on
without people walking away,
feeling like, 'We're
gonna lose this country.'"
And the truth is that
I'm hopeful and I'm optimistic,
or I wouldn't get up in the
morning. If I genuinely thought
that we had no shot at winning,
what would be my incentive
for getting up in the morning,
and doing this,
and producing the show?
And same for you, right?
What would be your incentive?
And I know I mentioned
this to you last night,
but you know,
there's also this
element of realizing
that the reason why they have
been so obviously corrupt,
right, it's never been
more in your face.
"Hey, we're just gonna teach
your kids pornography."
Right?
"Parents are
domestic terrorists."
Like, this is wild.
This is not even a good strategy
for the left to do this, right?
Well, they're losing control.
And when Barack
Obama was president,
they didn't need to censor,
they didn't need to kick
people off of platforms,
didn't need any of that
because they actually
owned the narrative.
They were winning.
In 2008,
the Democrat Party was
legitimately winning.
Right?
They didn't need to say,
"Mail-in ballots forever,"
or anything weird,
because they were
legitimately winning.
And we were all asleep.
Me being among them,
you being among them,
completely asleep at the wheel.
Well, now things have changed.
And because of that change,
because they feel like
they're losing grip,
they're becoming more desperate.
So, I tell people
to remain optimistic
and inspired by
their desperation.
- What do you
think their move is
as they get more desperate?
'Cause they can't let this
go on for too long, right?
This is what we were talking
about last night. It's like,
if enough of us are awake,
and if we're waking up people,
and they're seeing the truth,
and they can watch
the Rittenhouse trial,
see how MSNBC reports it
versus what's actually going on.
It's like,
the powers that be can't
let that exist for too long
because then they have a much
bigger problem on their hands.
- Well, you see their play. I
mean, you see Brian Stelter,
you have journalists that
are calling for censorship.
- [Dave] Yeah.
- Boggles my mind, right?
Some fourth estate, right?
They're literally saying to you,
"We're not the fourth estate.
We are part of the government,
we're a part of corporate media.
Our job is to protect
the government,
not to protect the individuals
that are being governed."
And you're seeing them call
for more and more censorship.
They're angry.
They're frustrated by the fact
that they spend all day
working on their show,
and maybe they get a
hundred thousand viewers.
And I can send a tweet
that will get more views.
They don't know what
to do with that.
And so, in their frustration,
they're demanding
more censorship.
But, it's like,
you can't censor people
until there's no more.
I think what's coming
up around the corner,
and something that
I've been telling people
to pay attention to,
is that The World
Economic Forum,
the same people that predicted
the coronavirus pandemic,
are now predicting
a cyber pandemic.
Where they predict
that because of the internet,
and things like Bitcoin
being uncontrolled,
that they're going to have
to physically shut down
the power grid
because there's
going to be a virus.
Literally, they give
"coronavirus for your computer"
is what they actually
said in this forum,
that is going to
spread very quickly.
So, they're gonna have to
shut down the power grid
to stop it.
And for a couple of
days, whatever it is,
you're not gonna have
access to your money,
or access to the internet.
And then, when they
turn things back on,
or to avoid a shutdown
like that again,
they're gonna need to
sanitize the internet.
This is actually language
that The World Economic
Forum is using,
sitting down with the biggest
corporations in the world,
talking about what
they are describing
as an inevitable coronavirus
pandemic for your computer.
That's the stuff
to pay attention to
because that would
allow them to,
similarly in the
COVID-19 pandemic,
usher in a bunch of things
that we've never seen before.
That, I think,
would provide a venue for them
to take control
over the internet,
to take out people
like me and like you,
to say that, "We had to
sanitize the internet
to keep everybody safe."
So, I always tell people
to kind of look around the
bend, hope it doesn't happen,
but always be aware of
any types of simulation
The World Economic
Forum is running.
- And then, at that point,
of two days, even,
even eight hours,
where we couldn't get online,
you wouldn't have
access to Twitter,
or your bank
account, or whatever,
people would beg
for the control at that point.
Right?
- Yeah, imagine New
York City, right?
So, imagine, maybe in Tennessee,
they'd be like, "All right,
we're gonna go hunting.
Oh, it's so great,
no internet, right?
This is great and amazing."
- You'll be all right-
- Yeah, I'll be all right.
- I saw George's cigar room.
- Right, exactly.
But, imagine a place
like Tennessee, which...
I mean, a place like New
York City or Los Angeles.
These people live, eat,
and breathe technology.
There is nothing without
technology in New York City.
It looks like a
piece of technology
(laughs) when you look
at it from the sky.
Right?
And so, imagine those
people not having access,
the whole power grid going down.
Let's say they do it
for four days, right?
And they would be
beside themselves.
They wouldn't know what to
do. These people don't...
I don't even know what
they would be eating.
What would happen to
the grocery stores?
They can't keep
refrigerators on.
I mean,
it would really
represent something
that would traumatize
these people,
rightfully so.
It'd be traumatizing thing
for them to go through.
Their livelihood would
be immediately impacted.
And when that power
grid went back on,
if the government
said like, you know,
"Now you have access to your
money, everything's back.
But, here's what we have to do
to make sure that four
days never happens again."
They will be the
first in line, right?
Just like they were the first
in line for the vaccine cards,
"Don't let us go
into restaurants."
Because they will be
so paralyzed by fear,
these individuals would then
be begging the government
for more censorship,
begging the government
to sanitize the internet,
begging saying,
"Whatever freedoms
you have take away
from me, take it.
I just wanna make sure
that that never happens again."
Back to our thesis
here about fear,
and how that, as a driver,
is the biggest
threat to humanity,
and freedom for humanity.
- All right. So, we only
got a couple of minutes left
'cause you got a show,
and I'm gonna do your show.
Very exciting.
- That's right.
- There's all these people
here, we should do another show.
So, in like three minutes or so.
What else is kinda on your mind?
Or, maybe, just
like more what...
Gimme like, Candice,
the Candace that I know,
not the Candace that
everybody else knows.
- Yeah.
I think, for me,
the next few years,
every day really is
about family for me.
Like, I don't think
people really get to see
the personal side of me
because you can't
let them in politics.
You know, (laughs)
they're just evil.
But, I try to just
tell everybody
that, "Family is the
most important thing,"
every single day.
And I try to,
if I can prescribe
anything upon the world,
it would be read the "Bible."
Not because you need
to be religious,
but because it has good values.
You know what I mean?
Read the "Bible"
as you would read
"Aesop's Fables,' right?
There's just good moralities
and lessons in there.
And I definitely am someone
that like, I'll just
peruse and read things.
And you go through
the scriptures
and you realize that...
You walk away with
an understanding
that evil is evil,
and it can always get more evil,
but in the end, goodness wins.
And I think that we
have to understand
that nothing is going to change
until we take care of
our households first.
Maybe this is the
Jordan Peterson,
"Make your bed."
Right?
So, invest that time,
when the world seems evil,
invest that time in making
your home a better place,
and making good personal
individual decisions.
And I think that
enough of us do that
and we save this place.
- I gotta tell you, Candace,
it's weird 'cause we do
this publicly and privately,
so there's this odd
lens around it sort of
in a public sense.
But, I am just so, truly,
I'm so proud of you.
It's like, that's what I
feel when I'm with you.
I feel like you're
doing something real.
And so many people
that I've come across
and they say, "It's not real.
It's fake, or it's confused,
or it's muddled, or something."
And you're the real deal.
- [Candace] Thank you.
- And it's very cool that
I'm part of the adventure.
- Sill the same person, right?
Can you give me credit for that?
- And you love chicken parm!
That's something people
don't know about you,
you love a good chicken parm.
- I love all chicken.
That's why I want
chickens, actually.
My husband says I can't
have them in this house,
but we'll see.
I know how the game
works with wives,
we wear 'em down in the end.
I will have those chickens.
- If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful conversations
about politics,
instead of nonstop yelling,
checkout our politics playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode playlist.
All right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe
and click the notification bell.